foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
slightly different look for us here
today as we are here at the home Sky
News for one week only
well the look might be different but I'm
afraid the topic is to practically
familiar because once again we're
talking about some pretty groom
allegations of sexual misconduct at
Westminster this week the conservative
deputy chief whip Chris pincher resigned
after claims that he groped two men when
drunk the question now is what do the
Prime Minister know and when and there
are of course wider concerns about the
culture in Westminster drinking bad
behavior and critically a power
imbalance that it seems that some are
still taking advantage of difficult but
important topics to discuss with our
guests this morning in a moment we're
joined by the work and pension secretary
Therese Coffey the labor we'll be
talking to the shadow business secretary
Jonathan Reynolds with a wall grinding
on as Russia is making gains in Ukraine
debates here over military spending
we'll be talking to the former Chief of
the defense staff Lord danet and after
an extraordinary week a global diplomacy
in Europe an ongoing tension between the
UK and the EU I'll speak to Germany's
ambassador to this country Miguel Berger
following yesterday's 50th pride parade
in London we'll also be talking to Chris
Smith who made history in 1984 by
becoming the first openly gay MP he went
on to become the first openly gay
cabinet minister and we'll also talk to
the conservative Justin Greening who
actually came out on the day of pride in
2016 to become the first openly gay
woman serving in the cabinet she's a
former education secretary
[Music]
thank you
well let's start this morning with
another very difficult round of Sunday
headlines for the government focused on
sexual misconduct and the Judgment of
the Prime Minister we're now joined by
the work and pension secretary Terese
coffee thank you very much for being
with us good morning I'd like you to
remind you of course you know Pinchers
resigned had the whip suspended over
these allegations that he groped two men
at the Carlton Club on Wednesday night
in today's newspapers there are multiple
other allegations about his behavior
stretching back years
were you aware of these concerns around
the behavior of Mr pincher before this
week
I think first of all it's important to
set out that of course serious
allegations were made they were dealt
with decisively not only did uh the
previous day that Chris had already
resigned as deputy chief whip but when
people came forward and made those
formal complaints appropriately they're
now going to be investigated and it was
right then for the chief whip with the
agreement of the Prime Minister to
suspend the whip but
um you know I've been in Parliament the
same length of time as Chris pincher I
don't pretend to be part of the general
chatter Rumor Mill discussions I know
Chris hasn't been I don't believe he's
been a long-term relationship but that's
about as far as my knowledge goes
so just to be crystal clear
for this week were you aware of any
allegations or concerns over the
behavior of chrispincher
no I wasn't as I say I'm just not part
of that sort of uh kind of chatter group
as it were um and I mean to be fair to
be fair it's not a chatter group is it
this guy the last time he was in the
whips office he had to resign he
actually referred himself to the police
after some accusations it's not just
Westminster chatter there was serious
concerns about the behavior of this man
well Sophie um as you say he pointed out
um I think an allegation was made from
prior to when uh Chris pincer being an
MP
um and there was an investigation that
was uh Chris was cleared at the time and
he rejoined the government at that time
so obviously that was in the public
domain but um as I say these allegations
have been made and it's really important
that when such Behavior it's uh when
people are concerned about this instead
of just different elements that they
come forward and make those complaints
you know to the police if necessary and
I'm pleased that the this investigation
is now underway it's been dealt with uh
seriously and meanwhile the government
will continue to get on with delivering
uh priorities as it's trying to do in a
variety you wait okay
um you say you weren't aware of any
allegations around him I just want to
talk about what the Prime Minister knew
and when and because Boris Johnson of
course made Crispin to the Deputy Whip
in February
when he was given that job was the Prime
Minister aware of any allegations about
his behavior
well I don't know about any individual
conversations
um it's been suggested that there was a
discussion a referral to Pat which
happens with all ministerial
appointments actually that there's an
element of a bit of vetting that goes on
but ultimately the decision is that of
the Prime Minister uh I'm clear that I'd
say I'm not part of those individual
conversations
um Chris had served in government before
and uh was had been a minister elsewhere
so I'm not aware that there was anything
that was brought to the attention the
prime minister to make that change
sorry I'm still not really clear
um you say you weren't aware of any
reports
uh you say that everyone is passed on
for vetting if they you know become a
given a position what's the Prime
Minister aware of allegations around
Chris pinch's behavior when he was made
deputy chief whip in February well I've
just said to you I'm not involved in any
of those direct conversations well why
don't but why don't you ask but I just I
don't you know I I get you know perhaps
it's easier just to be able to come on
these programs and say look I don't know
so who knows but but surely you must ask
to try and find out you know that's the
first thing that most people would do
when did the Prime Minister know so that
when I am asked this question I can give
the answer
well as I've just outlined to you what
um has been suggested in terms of uh
things were referred uh but nevertheless
when somebody phoned the Prime Minister
uh particularly on Friday I think it was
um he agreed with the chief whip that
these uh whip should the whip should be
suspended sorry I I genuinely don't
understand that sentence that um it was
suggested and things were referred I
don't what does that mean
well I think it's been well laid out um
Sophie that uh when the appointment for
becoming deputy chief whip again
um moving from a different ministerial
post uh it was uh that went through
vetting process like normal
um but as I say I'm not directly
involved in those discussions um I'm not
going to try and do so and I'm not part
of that more General uh kind of rumor
speculation meal within Westminster uh
but nevertheless sorry I just got a
question again I'm just going to come in
again apologies
um
just gonna give you the same answer
Sophie but I don't I don't understand
the answer I forgive me you say it was
well laid out that he went through a
vetting process like normal but the
question is where was the Prime Minister
aware of allegations about his behavior
I'm I'm not aware that he was made aware
of like specific claims about uh um any
particular incidents or anything like
that no I'm not I don't believe he was
aware that's what I've been told today
um but uh that's uh you were asking more
about more General rumors and I've no
idea what conversations have been had
I'm just I am aware that he the Prime
Minister was not aware of specific
claims that had been made and as I say
when ultimately he resigned uh Chris
resigned the whip sorry resigned as
deputy chief Whip and then when specific
things were brought directly to the
attention of the prime minister they
agreed with the chief whip to suspend
the whip okay so you say that as far as
you know the Prime Minister was not made
aware of specific claims in 2017 so I
feel that's quite important if you just
look at what's in the papers today
Sunday Mirror the front page the Prime
Minister was worn twice a concerns on
the deputy chief whip then on Sunday the
Prime Minister knew all about groping
Tori two years ago the Sunday Telegraph
the PM turned a blind eye to the sex
pest warnings they say that Craig
Whitaker actually resigned from the
whips office because of the prime
minister's decision to appoint Chris
pincher we know of course uh Dominic
Cummings tweeted this week to say if the
PM didn't know about Pinscher as he's
claiming why did he repeatedly refer to
him laughingly in number 10 as pincer by
name pincher by Nature long before
appointing him do you really believe the
Prime Minister was not aware of any
specific allegations
um I've just suggested or said I don't
think the PM was aware of specific
claims no it was new to me in the
morning this morning to read the reason
given why Greg Witter resigned from
government uh and I have no idea what
dominic Cummings tweets on anything so I
don't follow his uh Twitter handle
okay okay
um there's been a bit of a shifting
position from number 10 uh which we're
trying to kind of grapple with
um initially we said the Prime Minister
didn't know now number 10 seemed to be
saying that some allegations were raised
at the time that he got the job in
February's reshuffle but the quotas in
the absence of any formal complaint it
was not appropriate to stop the
appointment on the basis of
unsubstantiated allegations
do you believe that's the correct
position that it was the right thing
just to give him the job even despite
the fact that there were these
unsubstantiated allegations
I think the Prime Minister made the
choice he thought was best of it for the
interests of the Parliamentary party
we've been through an interesting and
sorry the government in order to help
get government business through uh Chris
had been a minister for some time in
different departments and went back into
the wic's office as I say the uh there's
a number of activities we are trying to
get on with in in terms of government
and getting legislation through the
house as so we can get on and deliver
people's priorities
um that's the sort of thing that we're
doing uh right now with just passed a an
act of parliament in order to make sure
we can make cost of living payments to
other people so it's it's there are a
variety of ways of all reasons why
somebody will be asked to fulfill a
particular role I just want to ask you
personally you know because we know
obviously that victims of sexual
misconduct of sexual assault can be very
reluctant to make formal complaints
particularly if there's a power
imbalance obviously
um
given that there were these
unsubstantiated allegations do you think
that it was right for Chris pincher to
be appointed to that important job in
February
well what I think is right is that
people should have the confidence come
forward whether they want to do that
through the icgs which has been set out
obviously it's not the question that I
asked well I'm explaining that I think
it's important that people should have
the confidence to follow the procedures
that have been put in place deliberately
because of uh situations like this I'm
very wish people would go to the police
more with allegations uh if they feel uh
that a crime is being committed but
importantly I think that uh we as I said
earlier I'm not prone to privy to the
exact conversations that went on I have
been told that pm has not made aware of
specific claims uh and indeed there's an
aspect of a vetting process that every
ministerial appointment goes through but
ultimately it's positioned the Prime
Minister and I believe he made that in
good faith
you know I can't help with thinking that
a lot of people listen to this
will be feeling frankly that you're
dancing on the head of the pin by saying
specific allegations
that he was aware of General concerns
but because you're going to say specific
allegations do you think you can just
wiggle out of it
it's not a case of that I've said at the
very beginning Sophie I'm not priority
to conversations that the Prime Minister
has it on on this topic or indeed many
other topics all I know is uh that uh
Ali want serious allegations have been
made the effective action has been taken
is the real problem here
that the fact is that the standards of
this government are set by the Prime
Minister how can he rigidly enforce them
if he himself has broken the law in
office we know of course that he's been
investigated on everything from how he
refurbished his flat to whether or not
he lied to Parliament or misled
Parliament to top that off his ethics
Chief has Justified just resigned he's
not even going to bother replacing him
it's the real issue the fact that the
standards of this government are set
from the top
what I see from the prime minister is
the leadership that he's showing one
tackling issues in this country where
that's the priority of trying to level
up across the country I also see his
leadership in the world he's just spent
the week particularly with Commonwealth
but also with the G7 and Nation this
kind of thing doesn't matter then is
that what you're saying because
you know standard State matter what I'm
saying is the leadership qualities of
the Prime Minister are very evident I
think on other matters of course uh the
it's the Privileges committee that will
be considering uh the investigation
about whether the Prime Minister
knowingly misled Parliament and indeed
for this situation involving Chris
pincher that now needs to go through its
formal process so it's important that
those issues and those processes are
followed and indeed I'm not quite sure
how committee gets underway but they
will be
um I want to talk about the wider
culture in Westminster now in the last
year this has happened five times Chris
pincher Imran Khan Bob Roberts David
Warburton Neil Parish or conservative
MPS who have resigned or been suspended
for allegations of sexual misconduct I
mean there are 271 male conservative MPS
in the last year alone five of them have
been suspended that is an incredible
ratio is there a specific problem with
conservative men
I don't think that's the case at all
Sophie
um I don't know the situation the
scenarios Elsewhere One MP well no
longer an MP Imran Khan has been
convicted of an something that happened
before he became a member of Parliament
and other investigations are underway so
I'm not going to comment on individual
investigations because it's process
needs to be followed I understand that
and I'm not asking you to do that um
let's let's you know because it does
feel frankly that you know we're sitting
in studios in every regular regularly
we're talking about the culture of
Westminster we're talking about these
kind of misconduct allegations and what
I'm interested in now is what do you
think should happen there are six odds
in the Commons and the Lords there are
30 in the Parliamentary estate is it
time to seriously talk about closing
parliament's bars
well I think um in terms of parliament's
bars we have a particular sort of
working hours we have particular and a
lot of these situations that you're
referring to I don't think happened in
the bars so um that's a a matter I guess
for discussion within Parliament but
we've already reduced the number of
drinking and eating Outlets within
Parliament but importantly what does
matter in terms of culture is actually
being a government and a parliament that
gets on and deliver
the priorities of the people okay that's
what I will continue to do and that's
what I see it sounds like the majority
of people it sounds like you're not uh
seriously looking at closing
parliament's bars and how about reform
of working practices as speakers talked
for example about MPS no longer directly
employing staff so it's easier for them
to make HR complaints Andrew lessons
talked about maybe having a proper HR
System for Parliament is that something
that can change
well an HR System for Parliament has
been introduced so I'm not quite sure
what the background to that is it's
always been the case that MPS had
parliamentary support in terms of the
fact that they are employers but there
is a separate process now where people
can get advice and do you think anything
should change the staff belong to a
trade Union as well do you think
anything else should change around
working you know the working structure
in Parliament
well I think that we have a parliament
uh in Westminster we sit for more hours
than anywhere else in the world we have
two chambers of the debate so it's a
very busy with the select committees
with all sorts of other activities that
go on so there is a certainly a huge
amount of time spent understandably uh
so no change but no important issues so
no specific changes then if you don't
think I'm not aware of specific changes
I think it's important that MPS continue
to employ the people who work for them I
think that relationship is really is
okay absolutely critical but
nevertheless uh as I say over the past
few years new processes have been
introduced uh in terms of that but
meanwhile most of the staff most of the
MPS are just getting on doing their
absolute job of representing
constituents or indeed scrutinizing
legislation and that's to say why we are
working on things like the cost of
living challenge uh also elements you
know trying to help people in their
daily lives this summer a lot of people
perhaps not so confident of the weather
of the British of Britain trying to get
abroad and
I will talk to you about that in a
minute but it just it just sounds like
you know you there's no change that you
think is necessary even though the
Sunday Times is reporting 56 MPS
apparently being investigated for sexual
misconduct five conservative employees
had to resign in the last year alone no
change I just want to ask you you know a
personal question because because I get
that it's it's a difficult position that
you're in this morning I understand that
um you know how's it been
um to have been you know like a woman in
the conservative party listening over
the last couple of years to some of
these allegations that have been made
victims speaking out often anonymously
and because they feel that they can't do
so on the record
the reputation of parliament is it is so
low and it does really feel doesn't it
as if there's so many concerns about the
behavior of MPS how does it feel for you
absolutely I think there are more women
in peace in Parliament than ever before
and
um I can assure you if people approach
me I would do my best although uh dare I
say it's uh going to the icgs is the
best way for people to uh lodges Lodge
complaints in order to tackle that you
know we have to be professional there
are different situations that happen
where people have been unprofessional
and unpleasant and that needs to be
tackled absolutely I'm very much in
favor of firm and dealing with these
things firmly and I can translate the
situation that is what has happened but
uh you know we need to continue to try
and encourage people to come forward and
as I say go to the police if they
believe that a crime has been committed
nobody in that regard should be feeling
that they've got some protection they
haven't we need to continue to try and
make sure we have the highest standards
Behavior especially in the Palace of
Westminster okay there you go
um to move on to talk about some other
subjects now
um there's chaos at the airport you
mentioned it earlier holiday has been
ruined thanks to canceled flights the
fact that there is a staffing crisis the
government's fast tracking Security
checks for new airport bag handlers to
try and improve things what's the idea
and are there any security concerns
around this
well certainly airports um and other
airlines released a lot of people after
the furlough schema come to an end
perhaps not anticipating the desire for
people to get out of the country that's
why we've been running job fairs in
places like that WIC airport in order to
get people into that work I think it's
really um the the government has
responded we've reduced the amount of
time in order to do various checks I
think counter-terrorism is now down to
10 days so we've prioritized that
recognizing the pressures on airlines
this summer but also I know Blanchard's
the transport secretary had already made
some changes so people could start
training in less secure parts of the
airport rather than waiting for the full
checks so together we have been putting
forward our approach in order to help
the airlines but what it's really
matters that when airlines offer flights
that they have confidence these can be
delivered and indeed making sure that
their passengers know well in advance
whether or not their flight's going to
be honored not making cancellations at
the last minute of course I'm joking for
people to stay in this country and spend
a lot of money in the UK but I
understand that it's important that they
have a system that they have confidence
in and rightly they'll get compensation
if flights are suddenly canceled okay um
we're in a slightly strange position
aren't we where it's almost like the
jobs Market is a bit too hot you have
very low unemployment levels but a
record level of vacancies 1.3 million
now the business Minister Paul Scully at
Telstar news recently that effectively
people who want to should work longer
hours to try and ease this he said there
are record number of vacancies there are
also people who have recalibrated what
they want to do when they're on furlough
we want to make sure that those people
that are not necessarily working
full-time through Universal Credit we
can get them back into work to be more
productive
do you agree with him that perhaps
people recalibrated what they wanted to
do during the pandemic and actually it
may be a good time to try and boost
their hours
well I think that's a fair um kind of
top level analysis certainly when people
were put on furlough others they started
looking for other types of jobs
um they re-sort of different work-life
balance I think there is something here
about employers thinking about the
flexibility they can offer about whether
everything has to be a 12 shift starting
at 4am or whatever it is
so to try and make that more attractive
to people to come and do that job again
certainly in terms of people on benefits
and out of work in the last five months
we've got over half a million people
into work through our way to work
campaign that's a real achievement we've
had some record highs of getting people
to work in the last few months and we
will continue to do that but it's
important that we try and get people to
progress in work as well but we'll keep
trying to match those vacancies and as I
say we're at the moment we're having a
monthly jobs fair in Gatwick Airport to
try and bridge that Gap okay and then
just very finally because we are almost
out of time and Boris Johnson's an
election pledge to build 40 new
hospitals by 2030 is is now facing a
review by the government spending
Watchdogs they're looking into value for
money review whether the hospitals will
in fact be new it was such a big part of
the election campaign was not I remember
that pledge really well it's not a great
look at them
well off the top of my head I'm trying
to remember the numbers I think we've
already done six I think there are five
in progress
um and underway and this is a reasonably
long-term project the Neo is the is
actually parliament's an organization of
Parliament and it's up to them to work
with the Public Accounts committee to
decide what elements they want to
investigate in terms of the use of
taxpayers money so it's uh we are
getting on with that job and I know many
communities around the country are
really appreciating the additional
facilities the rebuilt facilities as
well as the brand new facilities in
order to make sure that they have 21st
century Healthcare available to treat
them as patients okay thank you very
much for being on the program this
morning through his coffee there for the
government
what we can turn to labor now and talk
to the shadow business secretary uh
Jonathan Reynolds um I'm sure you were
listening to that interview uh Terese
coffee said that the Prime Minister was
not aware of specific claims about the
behavior of Chris pincher when he was
made deputy chief whip in February
what did you make of that
well I I thought part of that were
desperate to be honest I think we've got
to acknowledge what the consistent
problem is and it is a conservative
party that repeatedly chooses to do what
is politically expedient over what is
right and that's whether that's the
matter of those MPS that were charged
with serious sexual offenses at Charlie
elthick and Andrew Griffiths who were
then let back into the conservative
party because that was the short-term
interest they adopted it's clear from
what we know this morning that Chris
printer should never have been put back
into the whips office it's a wider
pattern of behavior too isn't it an Owen
Paterson breaking the rules and then
having the secret because everybody
seeking to redraw those rules to his
advantage and if you have a situation no
matter what else is going on where
people believe no matter what they do
they will not be held accountable to
that because of their relationship to
Boris Johnson or the position or the
internal politics of the conservative
party I think you are asking for the
kind of problems which they have got and
I'm so frustrated that again the whole
reputation of politics in Parliament in
this country is being besmirched by this
I accept that the more recent cases have
been skewed towards the conservative
party I do accept that but there have
been issues within the labor party as
well had they not
um the majority MPS conservative but
Mike Hill Ivan Lewis Calvin Hopkins all
labor MPS who've resigned in the last
few years uh over their conduct the
investigation to Calvin Hopkins didn't
even reach a conclusion because it took
so long that he resigned as membership
and the complainant in that case labor
activist tweeted to say that she hopes
Kirsten listens to her concerns and
fixes this broken system labor is also
not squeaky clean on this are you no
well a case like that is not acceptable
and I can tell you it wouldn't happen
again I suppose we can start a business
secretary I'm a member of the labor
party's national executive committee I
have the humility selfie to know yes we
have problems I'm often a person who has
to respond and deal with those but I can
tell you that we don't have what I
observe in the conservative party which
is the repeated decision to make the
wrong decision if that's in whatever
short-term interest they perceive they
have I don't think they've taken these
things seriously I think they've made
decisions which they shouldn't have made
I can't believe some of the things that
are in the papers today about what the
Prime Minister may have personally been
aware of before he made decisions like
this and but all the politics suffers
that there was no doubt about that it it
affects the reputation of us all and
that's what I find so frustrating and I
think it's right that people demand
better
you know it feels kind
of thing that you know I do these
interviews about these stories on a
regular relatively regular basis and I
often ask people what should actually
change in Parliament and it feels as if
people just don't come up with any
answers there is coffee was defending
the use of bars defending the use of MPS
directly employing their staff and I
just wonder what your position is on
that 30 bars in the Parliamentary estate
six in the House of Commons the House of
Lords is it now time to shut the bars
look I I don't think Sophie Parliament
has the kind of modern workplace culture
that it should have I think that's
further to go on that but I would just
say if you look at these particular
incidents actually a few of them are in
Parliament itself so for me it comes
down to something bigger than the
hospitality Arrangements it's about
power it's about accountability it's
about the the standards that are set by
the leader and while the leader of each
political party and I cannot see Boris
Johnson as being the kind of person to
somehow improve the culture of the
conservative party he himself you know
we don't even need to go through the
things that he has been involved just to
go back to the question just to go back
to the question you don't think there's
a need to shut parliament's bars then
well I think there is only one major bar
for members of parliament there's a one
for staff as well I'm not sure the other
ones are probably the restaurants but no
I don't think that is the issue I think
the problem is not you could shut every
bar in Westminster but if you've got a
conservative party that does not take
these issues seriously that gives people
a get out of jail but genuinely you know
I do think most people are listening to
this just won't understand like lots of
people work long hours lots of people
work late very very few people work in
workplaces where there is a drinking
culture that is effectively encouraged
because you have bars in Parliament
well I I wouldn't say it's encouraged
most people are doing an incredibly
professional job and where there are for
instance there's a bar for staff members
I think that is to be honest absolutely
fine what I'm trying to say to you is
this is not the core of the issue you
know I think particularly the Chris
pinch against I understand was that the
conservative parties private members
Club the Carlton Club so there are other
issues down the bars that cannot be
decide to see we've got to address the
core of this which is poor Behavior
that's been set from the top what about
um what about the idea put forward by
the speaker that MP should no longer
directly employ their own staff which
would obviously make you know HR
complaints easier if it's your direct
line manager that is you know the issue
I'd have no complaints personally about
that I think as long as MPS are able to
select their interview and select the
right staff members for them I would
also say the most important thing just
just just to come in if you don't mind
um because you you obviously are upset
by the story I get it you know you
you've come on in very strongly
explained why you find it troubling but
what do you think should change I
understand that you're going to give me
an answer at the conservative party but
surely we should be looking at things
that can practically change in
Parliament to try and stop this kind of
behavior or at least make a bit of a
difference for me it comes down to our
MP is going to be held accountable for
their actions are they going to have the
right standard of leadership set from
the topic is there going to be you know
some of the people were talking these
are good words but there's no actual
change there is there well it wouldn't
be change if people took this seriously
and therefore made decisions accordingly
if you have a situation where someone
has resigned for a certain set of
behaviors and you then appoint them not
just to the whips office but to be in
charge of the welfare of other MPS well
of course that's the wrong decision
that's what needs to change that just
clearly hasn't been a factor in the
prime minister's considerations here at
all okay
um there's just to move on to some other
issues now there's chaos at the airports
at the minute anyone trying to pick a
holiday will be very well aware of it
and the government's come forward with
some plans today where they want to fast
track track Security checks for baggage
handlers that trying to use the staffing
issues does labor support that or are
you worried about any security risk well
I want to see the Department of
Transport get a grip on this travel of
chaos I saw that story last night to be
frank I think they'd probably just come
up with that to try and get through the
media round today there seems to me to
have been no planning at the stage of
the pandemic that required it to look at
what would happen when we came out of
the pandemic in terms of the job losses
that had taken place at airports in
particular about the complex
relationship between the home office
employees the airline staff and the
airport staff to make sure we had the
capacity to do it so it feels like
they're playing a little bit of catch-up
today but they do need to get a grip of
it okay
um and then just finally uh Tony Blair
said this week on a podcast that he
supports what kirstheimer is doing but
he then went on to say the central
problem is what are the ideas that are
going to stop this relegation and put
the UK on an upward path there's been a
gaping great whole where ideas should be
do you agree that there's been a gaping
great hole where ideas should be no I
think there's a bit of Gap in Great Hall
but I think Tony Blair's analysis of
what this country needs in terms of
having a plan to turn around the last
decade of poor growth poor productivity
downward pressure on wages is absolutely
essential I was doing a big speech this
week at the um Society of motor
manufacturers Summit about how the state
could be a partner to make sure we've
got the battery factories that we need
in order to make sure we continue to
make electric vehicles in this country
and don't lose out to competitors and
that is what is required if you look at
the conservative party this government
what are they offering you bring back
Imperial measurements a trade war with
the European Union that is not the way
forward if you look at what we're saying
and of course we've got to develop this
it's that exciting long-term vision for
industrial policy in this country to
make sure there are good jobs and of
course that we hit our climate change
commitments so I think he's right to say
that's what this country needs but I
think labor is the party offering that
and the government frankly have just run
out of ideas okay thank you very much
for being on the program today Jonathan
Reynolds uh
so there you go
um lots of questions about the
allegations in Parliament today it did
feel doesn't it the two uh interviews
there and no specific ideas for what
should change going forward well let's
move on to some other subjects now uh
shall we Vladimir Putin's war on Ukraine
is grinding on relentlessly his forces
continue to take land in the donbass
despite the brave resistance there in
response NATO leaders have approved a
huge increase in high Readiness forces
they're also going to be deploying more
troops to Eastern Europe and that's led
to a debate here over whether it's time
for us to spend more on our defense and
what we should spend it on
well I'm pleased to say we're now joined
uh by the former Chief of the defense
staff Lord Richard Janet thank you very
much for being with us this morning
Sophie good morning I'm delighted to be
here
great well we're delighted to have you
um it felt like the beginning of the war
was really dominated by stories of
Ukrainian success and Russia failing to
meet their aims whether it was taking
cave or so on but now is it right that
that feels like it's turning and that
actually Russia is making steady
grueling progress but still progress in
the East is Russia now winning the war
um no I wouldn't say Russia is winning
the war it all depends what uh Russia's
objectives are considered to be your
analysis is absolutely right at the
start the ukrainians did extremely well
the Russians were woefully inept as far
as their military is concerned and they
realize that their desired lightning
strike from Belarus to keep just was not
going to happen that was the shambles
and that episode that chapter finished
and then they started what we've been
seeing working out over the last few
weeks and months this Relentless grind
in the donbass to take donets Province
and luhan's Province and to join up with
the land Corridor that the Russians have
achieved already from Crimea through
mariopol to to donbass but um the
Russian tactics and the Russian way of
doing business has completely changed
since that early failed attack they're
relying on their huge superiority in
artillery pounding the provinces of
donetska luhansk and then once they've
almost reduced everything to Rubble then
sending their troops into uh to take
possession of it and we're going to see
that slow grind continue they very
nearly achieved taking no hands Province
and then they will turn their sights to
trying to get the control of donets now
I think probably what we've seen over
the last few weeks shows that over the
next few days and weeks they will
probably achieve that and at that stage
I believe the Russians will be exhausted
they won't have won the war but they'll
have achieved some of what they want to
achieve getting those two Don best
provinces the ukrainians will also be
exhausted
um so the Russians went to one the
ukrainians won't have lost and at that
point I believe that the war will
effectively go in the deep into the deep
freeze and that's where meaningful
negotiations are going to have to start
well that's in a way is where the big
questions begin too if as you say it's
almost inevitable that Russia ends up
taking those two provinces in the
donbaths what then should the
International Community do should we
accept that Russia holds on to the
territory it takes in return for peace
well it's interesting you put the
question that way we shouldn't do
anything in terms of deciding what
should happen this has got to be the
ukrainians deciding what is going to
happen the worst outcome for the West
for those of us who have been supporting
Ukraine is for us to apply pressure on
the ukrainians to come up with some kind
of compromise some kind of deal with
Russia and for the ukrainians than to
criticize would be justifiably criticize
the West for saying well your soul is
short what we absolutely have to do in
the west is continue to support Ukraine
unequivocally continue pouring in
weapons and ammunition which we're doing
and it's up to president zielinski and
the ukrainians to decide what
negotiations they want to have with the
Russians and the fact of the matter is
if one looks at it objectively is that
once the Russians have captured as I
suggest they will the two provinces have
done excellent enhanced completely and
we've got that land Corridor the world
might tell them to go but the Russians
will not go and nobody can make together
the Russians won't go voluntarily the
ukonians will not be strong enough to
throw them out and of course the West
NATO has got no intention whatsoever of
mounting a Kuwait type sort of expulsion
operation such as we did to get rid of
Hussein's forces over from Kuwait that's
just not going to happen so the new
reality is that the Sovereign territory
of Ukraine probably is going to be
occupied to about 20 by Russian troops
and that's the accommodation that the
ukrainians have got to get their head
around they must get their head around
it we mustn't make them put their head
around it
that's really interesting because in a
way I've kind of wrongly thought of this
as a decision moment for Ukraine or for
you know the International Community
whatever that you either decide to
Russia is going to keep this land or
you're going to try and repel Russia but
actually perhaps the most likely
scenario is Russia maintaining control
of the donbass the war in deep freeze
but just going on
tragically and sadly that could be the
case and of course I don't know how far
you want to extend this conversation but
if we believe that's going to be the
scenario in Ukraine it then for the rest
of the West and particularly other
countries that border Russia there is
then the lingering threat of a resurgent
and domineering Russia which is why NATO
at its Summit quite recently has said
that it wants to increase from forty
thousand to three hundred thousand
hybrid in his troops not to fight the
Russians although troops must be trained
and prepared to fight the Russians but
to deter the Russians from further
aggression uh elsewhere whether it's in
the Baltic states or Poland or wherever
and again again extending the
conversation a bit more it comes back to
our domestic considerations
um under some pressure the Prime
Minister has now agreed to increase our
defense budget to move towards 2.5
percent of GDP by the end of the decade
but and here's another quite narrow
point but important point we're still
going going ahead in this country was
reducing our army by ten thousand troops
over the next few years frankly that's
some heaviness because if NATO is going
to go to 300 000 High Readiness troops
we've got to play our part in that and
reducing our army further this makes no
sense whatsoever so domestically we
welcome the rise to 2.5 of GDP but we
must reverse the cuts in numbers to the
Army and also increase our investment in
our army our land War fighting
capability I'm afraid the future is not
going to be returned to things
pre-24th of February the future is going
to be a grumpy resurgent Russia on the
borders of countries in Eastern Europe
we've got to play our part in deterring
further Russian aggression that's
interesting that you say that that cut
to treat number numbers is madness and
how what impact would it have on our
defense capability I mean I guess in
simple language are we going to be less
safe as a result
well we are in land Force terms we are
much less capable than we were 10 years
ago
um 10 15 years ago we were fighting two
difficult campaigns with our army in
Iraq and Afghanistan and doing them
simultaneously with an army of over a
hundred thousand we're coming down to an
army of 70 odd thousand and we could not
maintain operations at the scale that we
were doing 10 15 years ago
um people say you shouldn't focus on the
number you should focus on capability
well in the case of our Maritime and air
forces that is correct because those
services are platform based you've got
to have Smart ships you've got to have
Smart aircraft but when it comes to
old-fashioned fighting numbers do matter
and to have an army of only just over 70
000 30 down from wherever you were 10
years ago is going to leave us woefully
short if we find that we've got to
maintain large number of troops at high
Readiness forward deployed in Eastern
Europe
um it's a mere fact of life will will
break the remainder of are on me if our
army is not large enough are trained
well enough and equipped well enough to
do what the government of the day wants
us to do you you can't make people work
endlessly
um with two smaller numbers so numbers
in the terms of our land forces really
really matter
it's fascinating to listen to you
um now this week the former National
Security adviser Kim Derek said that
NATO has to be ready for a Russian
nuclear strike
do you agree and what does that mean
Well the West is always ready to respond
to a nuclear strike
um but let's not get carried away with
this we absolutely do not want to see
anybody using nuclear weapons in Europe
or elsewhere
um we all know from our history books
what the awful consequence was of the
two atom bombs uh in Japan in 1945
modern nuclear weapons are much more
powerful than that we don't even want to
see a small tactical nuclear weapon are
being used so
um I think Kim Derek it's perfectly
reasonable to say what he has said but
we should be under No Illusion that our
British nuclear deterrent is always at
high Readiness so is the United States
ready to watch whatever Russia might or
might not do
I think the thing that's really
important here is to keep this conflict
in Ukraine within the concept of what we
would call a limited War Limited in
geography uh and limited by the means
that are being used and one of the
limits is the tacit agreement that
neither side will use nuclear weapons
they might say they're prepared to do so
what's really important is that our
defenses already and I think the other
thing people have got to remember and
perhaps be a little bit less fearful is
Vladimir Putin can't get up one morning
and think well this is not going very
well I'm going to push the button even
within the Russian nuclear firing chain
it requires a number of people to
confirm that decision and confirm
certain actions so he can't just get out
of bed in the morning and push a button
it's not as simple as that but um
important thing is that our defenses are
ready but let's keep this below the
nuclear threshold and work it out in I
was going to say a civilized way well
what the Russians are doing is not
civilized but in a at least a a vaguely
rational way okay I understood uh very
briefly as we are at a time but there is
one more question I do want to squeeze
in we've seen of course
um these very upsetting stories about
British people being accused of being
mercenaries by Russia two more British
men are captured by the Russians and
again accused of being mercenaries is
there anything that the government can
do in this situation
well I think they can make
representations to Russia through
through the ukrainians
reminding that these are British
citizens but but you know um if people
for their own reasons decide to get
themselves involved in somebody else's
War they've really got to take the
consequences of of their own actions now
that said the death sentence being
passed on to former British servicemen
who have been held
um that's really quite outrageous those
those two for example were properly
enlisted in the Ukrainian Army and
therefore they should be treated like
prisoners of War be they Ukrainian or be
they British
um this whole business is most
unfortunate and I would certainly say to
anybody that's thinking of or going
adventuring a little bit into Ukraine be
very very careful
um this actually is not your fight but
if you found yourself being taken
prisoner by the Russians then frankly
um it may be out of your control it
maybe even better the British
government's hands
thank you so much for being on the
program this morning it's been really
interesting I've certainly feel like
I've learned something from the
interview thank you
well the NATO meeting this week was a
show of Western unity and strength in
the face of Russian aggression but
divisions of course do remain between
the UK and the EU closer to home
specifically over the Northern Ireland
protocol and the British government's
plans to change or scrap parts of it the
EU says it will respond with legal
actions some think it could lead to a
trade War so what is the state of the
relationship between the UK and the eu's
largest and most powerful Nation
Germany's ambassador to the UK Miguel
Berger joins us now thank you very much
for being with us
um I just want to start with Ukraine
after that interview with Lord dannett
who said that the perhaps the most
likely scenario is the war goes into
deep freeze Russia takes the donbass and
it's very difficult then to get those
Russian troops out is that also
Germany's assessment
yeah I think it's one of the possible
outcomes of this terrible war that we
might go into a deep freeze but you know
I would not exclude that Russia might
push towards Odessa because we have so
far not seen that Putin has scaled down
on his Ambitions and Putin is watching
very closely and the the unity of of the
Western Alliance but you know I think
the messages which came out of the G7
Summit especially the NATO Summit with
the 300 000 troops now on high alert I
think that at least has sent a very
strong message towards Russia
given the Russian aggression that you
speak of there do you feel that Germany
has been a bit sluggish in providing
heavy weapons to Ukraine particularly in
comparison to the UK and the US
no I I would say that the difference was
that in Germany we had really to change
totally our approach and that was made
by Chancellor Schultz in his speech very
early in February on site and vendor
which means really a total new approach
concerning 100 billion for the German
Army which means that we are going to
have the largest armed forces in Europe
again we have started later than the US
and UK sending heavy weapons but I think
the multi-uh rocket launchers which we
are sending together with us and UK but
also the hovitzer self-propelled
officers I think they are already having
an effect we always can and we have to
do more and Sophie my concern is really
that we as a as NATO as Western Alliance
we have to be capable of supporting
Ukraine if this war drags on for weeks
and months and that will be also a
challenge for our Armed Forces I
understand of course the shift in German
position but it has taken a while to get
to this point this is President zelenski
just two weeks ago every leader of our
partner countries and naturally the
chancellor Schultz of Germany knows
exactly what Ukraine needs it's just
that the deliveries from Germany are
still less than they could be it has
taken a long time for you to get here
you will acknowledge that yes as I said
we started later than other countries
with the delivery but you know we have
done other issues for example we did
exchanges of arms with the Czech
Republic allowing them to deliver
russian-made tanks to Ukraine we did the
same with Greece we send our missile
defense systems to Slovakia allowing
them to send systems that is something
that other countries have not done so if
you take the overall picture I think
Germany is very close to what the UK is
doing
um of course Germany is very reliant on
Russia for oil and gas do you think rely
on Russia for more than a third of its
gas and the German foreign minister has
said that there's a hybrid war going on
as Russia cuts those supplies to Europe
How concerned are you about the supply
of oil and gas
I think we have to be very concerned
especially on gas on oil we have managed
to reduce in the last two three months
the dependency from over 30 percent to
only 12 percent because you have an
international oil Market where you can
get oil from other countries on gas it's
not so easy you need infrastructure you
need LNG terminals we have invested in
them so we have bought four floating LNG
terminals which will arrive in Germany
before the end of the year
but obviously if Russia and Russia has
reduced gas delivery to only 40 percent
so Germany has declared gas emergency
and that means if this continues or if
Russia would really cut care supply that
we will have to stop delivery to some
sectors of our industry that heating in
the autumn and winter might turn into a
problem so I can tell you there is quite
some concern
um okay I want to talk to you a little
bit now about the Northern Ireland
protocol if I'm there you're in Belfast
last week do you accept that the
Northern Ireland protocol currently
isn't working and are you optimistic
that there is a solution that can be
found
yeah you know for me it was very
interesting these three days in Belfast
talking with with all stakeholders and
the impression I got especially from the
business Community is yes there are
problems especially for small retailers
and we think they need and they can be
addressed
the majority of business told us that
they are working very good with the
Northern Ireland protocol what they need
is certainty certainty in order to
attract investment and this certainty is
definitely damaged by the Northern
Ireland protocol bill and I can tell you
that we are very concerned
that this bill which is not only
um from the point of view of
international law it it it it would
really
um break an agreement which the United
Kingdom has signed and ratified only two
years ago but more than that it brings
uncertainty to Northern Ireland next
year we're going to have 25 years of the
Good Friday Belfast agreement and I
think it should be our joint Endeavor to
do whatever is possible to have a
functioning executive in Northern
Ireland an assembly and a business
Community which can move forward so just
to be clear she mentioned international
law that you believe that the Northern
Ireland protocol bail breaks
international law that it's effectively
illegal there is no doubt about it and I
think Theresa May has said all about
this position we share it
um this is breaking in agreement and I
think that lawmakers House of Commons
they should be very concerned about what
it means to break an international
agreement how that will be seen at the
international stage
how will it be seen what will the
reaction
you know it will obviously be seen as a
as a challenge to international law and
to rule of law in general and so I think
the best what can be done is to go back
into legality and that means let's
negotiate fine Technical and practical
Solutions on the basis of the protocol
the European Union is ready to do that
but what we also cannot accept is a
challenge and a risk to our internal
market so what would happen if the UK
government does press ahead with it are
we talking about a trade War
you know I I only can tell you at that
stage that all options are on the table
and I would not exclude anyone of that
but really our call is let's go back
into negotiations this is doable it's
solvable and it's in the best interest
of Northern Ireland okay
um just very very finally I'm going to
squeeze one more question in
um looking ahead we had to welcome in
Qatar if England win their group and all
the other rounds as well and Germany do
the same filming in the final
bearing in mind that you're a diplomat
who do you think would win that one
that will be a fantastic game because
always England against Germany in the
World Cups was uh were great games so
I'm really looking forward to that but
now first of all we are looking forward
to the women's uh European championship
in England and there we also have a very
strong women's team competing
well that is a textbook diplomats answer
I have to say thank you very much for
being on the program this morning thank
you thank you for having me
well we can speak now to the former
conservative MP and education secretary
Justin Green and great to have you on
the program uh today morning Sophie
yesterday was pride and back in 2016 you
chose that day to tweet today is a good
day to say I'm in a happy same-sex
relationship I campaigned for stronger
in but sometimes you're better off out I
absolutely love this photo of you I have
to say
um how important was that moment for you
uh I mean it was it was life-changing in
a way
um I've been a cabinet minister for
quite a while
and
not being frank about my relationship
had I genuinely felt it had held me back
I didn't feel like doing interviews on
you know my personal life as much as I
possibly would have done and I realized
that I had to become part of the
solution and I couldn't think of a
better time to do that tweet than on the
day of London Pride back in 2016 it was
actually as you alluded to just after
the the EU referendum and
really from that moment on I I just
think for me it was like a weight off my
shoulders and you know I do so much
campaigning now on leveling up and
social Mobility but I think you know you
can't be at your best if you can't be
yourself and so for me life got a lot
better when I I could be myself
I find it
but I guess in some ways to really
understand that you know you're someone
who is incredibly successful woman
you're confident you've been a cabinet
minister you've done numerous interviews
including on this Shaman for many years
and yet you felt that it did take quite
a long time for you to in your words to
be yourself
yeah I just think it's why things like
London pride and all those other you
know marches and celebrations
um around the country matter because
actually we're on a journey and and I'm
gonna guess there may be some I was a
cabinet minister watching other people
like David Mundell say this is who I am
and so yes at the end of the day
it is a very personal
um thing to do but I also think it was
up to people like me to show some
leadership almost if you weren't past
the solution then you were part of the
problem you were sort of saying you
thought there was a problem with your
relationship and I really don't think
there is so I all I would say is it was
a hugely positive step for me there's a
lot more campaigning to be done on LGBT
plus rights on on that
um what campaigning do you think needs
to be done what issues well we've seen
homophobic hate crime rise actually
quite significantly over the past four
years I think when you look at access to
healthcare mental health issues there's
a whole range of different aspects I
think for the LGBT plus community that
people would like to see better
addressed but also I think when you look
at say for example on women's rights
over in the states and the rolling back
of Roe v Ward on abortion rights now
discussions around whether that will
translate across other rights
like for the LGBT plus Community I think
just this underlying assumption in the
past may be the rights generally get
better but that's not always the case so
we have come a long way we've now got
same-sex marriage you can have adoption
obviously as well all sorts of things
but actually we shouldn't just assume
that we won't get pushed back and I
think that's why Pride yesterday and all
of the campaigning that people do
matters so much it's interesting about
that um you know kind of rights under
attack if that feeling um are you
concerned about same-sex marriage in the
U.S
well the only time will tell but it
really worries me
that you can have a country like the
states with its democracy and then
judges who have been ultimately a
political appointees almost randomly
over different presidential terms
depending on who died when with so much
power
and I think then the challenge is yes of
course codify these rights and
legislation but if you also then have a
a state side politics and and democracy
that is often gridlocked it's bit half
and half down the line between
Republicans and Democrats then it is
hard for them to actually do that so
you're just left with a supreme court
taking away rights but a political
system not able to put them in place for
the long term where they should be in
law on Roe versus Wade and
um are you concerned about the what it
means to the UK we've seen of course
some MPS calling for the right to an
abortion to be included in the British
Bill of Rights
I think it puts a question out there
that none of us really
had anticipated which is the women's
rights may be pushed back
when actually the debate is how do we
move them forward still so I hope that
within Parliament surely there has to be
a consensus
that it's a question of how you move
forward not moving backwards but I think
what the states tells us is that we
can't just assume that and I think for
not just female parliamentarians but but
you know men and women the cross-party
consensus as well that we've had I think
it's time to redouble those efforts
whether it's on gender pay Gap and some
of those policy areas that government's
got whether it's the campaigning around
um around abortion whether it's around
just generally seeing women do better
across Society all of those things
really really matter I think
um at the beginning when I was talking
to you about you know different
campaigns for LGBT you mentioned
homophobic cake where I'm going up which
is again something that in the research
the interview I saw and actually it was
quite sort of shocked by I guess and
it's not what I had expected you kind of
think that these things will just
progressively get better why I think
maybe an impossible question but but why
do you think it does seem as though
these crimes are going up
I think it's because
they're there there are people in every
country but including ours who just
think this has all gone too far and and
in spite of all of the broader progress
um across the mainstream in a sense of
society there are
some parts of our society who just don't
accept that
and the problem is I think particularly
also in an internet age they're able to
sort of find one another and have those
conversations themselves validate them
which is why it does really matter that
you keep the fight going on LG LGBT plus
rights
um now that I have you I do need to ask
you obviously about the allegations and
the conservative party and we've seen of
course the resignation of Chris pincher
um truce coffee said that the Prime
Minister wasn't aware if in her very
careful language specific allegations
when he was appointed to be deputy chief
whip in February
um is that good enough
well look I think any time you end up
with an MP embroiled in these sorts of
allegations one of two things is going
to happen either the MP themselves will
take responsibility and own it and work
out what they do next or it ends up
being the party led by a prime minister
so one of those two things is going to
happen either Chris pincher as we get to
the bottom of these allegations we'll
have to take responsibility and decide
what he does but if that is not done
then yes it will reflect on The Wider
conservative party particularly in
Parliament led by Boris Johnson and
that's why I think for a lot of the
Parliamentary party this comes back to
Boris Johnson's leadership now the way
out of this in the long term setting
aside what needs to happen on this
particular case
is to do exactly what Caroline knows
Karen Bradley to highly respect to
senior female parliamentarians have
suggested which is to get a code of
conduct in place so we are not seeing a
prime minister and a party having to
just decide on the hoof in each specific
case it is a clear process that people
go through and then everybody is
transparent and clear-cut about what
would happen next and it is now time to
put this on a much firmer footing you
say time to put it on a firmer footing
because as you say this is not a really
an isolated case we've had five
conservative MPS resigning or being
suspended in the last year
for allegations of sexual misconduct
it's pretty extraordinary really is this
now having an impact on the effectively
the brand or the conservative party
I think in the end it's all it's all
about delivery Boris Johnson has an
agenda of leveling up delivering a
quality of opportunity he has to get on
with that but I think if people feel
that delivery isn't happening fast
enough and then they see these other
aspects of how the party is behaving in
Parliament and it gives you this sense
that actually there's not a focus on
that delivery for for Joe public like
there needs to be then it it creates
this broader impression of
a party that's in government but not
really driving this country forward
which is absolutely what we need right
now Britain has had long-term persistent
systemic inequality of opportunity and
it will take leadership Drive energy and
policy
to change that and that's why it's so
important that there are some clear
decisions taken about these sorts of
cases so that the government can get on
with that agenda for which I actually
think there is cross-party support but
at the moment of course it feels like
attention is anywhere apart from that
um just finally uh going back to the
start of the interview and you obviously
came out of Pride were you there
yesterday I wasn't able to be there
yesterday
so it was probably one of the first
years I've missed it since that tweet
but I'll look forward to being there uh
next year definitely
photos they were absolutely fantastic
thank you so much it was great to talk
Justin Greening bear thank you
and now as we were just saying yesterday
of course the 50th pride in London
parade where thousands of LGBT people
and supporters protested and celebrated
in the Streets of London and in 1984 at
a rally in rugby against a possible ban
on gay Council employees Chris Smith
said good afternoon I'm Chris Smith I'm
the labor MP for Islington South and
Finsbury and I am gay he instantly
became the first opening amp in House of
Commons there are now of course dozens
in a further Landmark moment he also
became the first openly gay member of
the cabinet we can now speak to Chris
Smith or Lord Smith we should say he's
also Master at Pembroke College
Cambridge and he joins us now
um how difficult was the decision you
made in 1984 and what was the reaction
oh I was absolutely scared stiff I um uh
partly because no one had ever done this
before
um uh I it was a spur of the moment
decision I had decided that at some
point I I wanted to say something about
myself
because I think it's much more important
to be open and honest about to and what
you are when you're a public
representative
um but the only question was when was
the right moment to do it and I can
remember walking into the Hall in rugby
about a thousand people packed into the
hall and as I walked up to take my seat
on the platform I just thought this is
the moment to do it and um uh I I have
to say the next 10 minutes before I
stood up were some of the scariest of my
life my hands were shaking my knees were
knocking together I I had no idea what
the response was going to be
and what was um what was the response do
you think
um uh well the in the hall it was
ecstatic um uh the the uh entire
audience got to their feet and gave me a
standing Invasion
um uh it's the only time I've ever had a
standing ovation 30 seconds into a
speech
um but uh the um uh the the best thing
that happened uh was in the week or so
afterwards I got letters from all around
the country
um
this was long before the days of social
media
um so people wrote letters and uh I I
got hundreds of letters some of which
said uh well done congratulations
um but the ones that I think made the
most to me were the ones that said thank
you this has made it easier for me
that's um as you say I kind of really
imagine how those ones must have just
been you know quite an incredible thing
to receive really
um and to know that you have made a
difference in that way
um of course back in 1984 you were the
only openly a gay MP in Parliament now
there are I think 60 MPS who have openly
said that they are LGBT
um but despite the progress that has
clearly been made I was just talking
about this with Justin Greening as well
homophobic hate crime is actually
increasing and how concerned are you
about that and do you think that you
know some progress is perhaps not as
easy as we assume I'm uh I'm very
concerned about the bullying that goes
on in schools the abuse that people get
to the homophobic hate crime uh that has
been happening and we have only to think
for example about the Stephen Port case
to uh to know that there is still a
serious problem out there
um but
in many ways we have made a lot of
progress
um a lot of legislation has been changed
uh there are now as you say huge numbers
of openly gay members of parliament
um uh we see other public figures coming
out uh the young footballer who recently
came out for example uh incredibly Brave
wonderful moment for him and for the
LGBT community
um so
um at the same time as the
homophobic abuse is happening you also
have considerable progress being made
and we just have to keep on steadily
making the progress not taking anything
for granted not allowing the government
for example to get away with omitting
trans people from the ban on conversion
therapy
um we we need to campaign for LGBT
rights around the rest of the world
many countries
with a legacy of colonial Administration
from the UK have kept Victorian laws on
their statute books
um now there's a huge amount still to be
done
but we also need to be um we need to be
glad about what has happened and what we
have been able to achieve and that's why
a moment like celebrating the 50th
anniversary of pride is so important
um to your right
um while I've got you just finally
um the news today of course is dominated
by yet another sexual misconduct Scandal
Chris pincher just the latest
resignation
what do you think was worse the sleaze
Scandal under John Major or the one that
the conservative party is currently
going through oh this is infinitely
worse
um the um because there is just so much
of it and uh it's not just the
occasional
um uh looking at a at that porn in the
House of Commons on your iPhone or
furtively
um groping uh young men in the Carlton
club uh it's not just those sort of
things
um it it's the Scandal the real Scandal
of all the contracts which were issued
in a hurry to untested untried companies
um uh in the first outbreaks of of kovid
it's the um the ignoring of the law of
the country so frequently in Downing
Street
there's a whole Litany of stuff it is
infinitely worse than it was was before
infinitely worse there you go thank you
so much for coming on the program it was
lovely to hear your story about what
happened when you first decided to come
out so thank you so much thank you very
much
well pretty varied uh program today I
think you'll probably agree that is it
for this week's Sophie Ridge on Sunday
in a moment after the break we're going
to run through today's interviews
including of course that one with
Therese coffee see what we learned we
joined by our Deputy political editor
Sam Cope's interested to hear his views
on that thank you for joining us this
Sunday morning
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we support communities to grow food in
Lost and unloved spaces across the city
so our main kind of driving force is to
get people growing
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Ridge the take where we take a moment
and reflect on some of what we've heard
over the last hour and we've heard quite
a lot over the last hour not least of
course about the story of question and
really The crucial question about what
the Prime Minister knew and when did we
find much out when we're trying to work
it out we'll be joined by our Deputy
political editor at Sam coat as we
dissect all of the reaction to just the
latest misconduct uh Scandal to hit the
conservative party
uh so we can bring in at Sam at this
point uh shall we um it's been one of
those weeks for the government where it
feels like
the plates have been spinning they've
been trying to work out exactly what
they should say and when and I feel like
we've learned a new phrase this morning
about specific allegations which feels
to me loaded with meaning
that's right Sophie good morning
to be fair I thought that the
conversation that you had with trees
coffee this morning was striking in many
ways it was excruciating uh and it was
remarkable to watch a veteran cabinet
minister side step resort to the passive
tense try and swerve around questions
but then again what is a cabinet
minister to do on a morning like this
morning where they are sent out to
defend the Prime Minister on the central
question of what he knew and when about
a senior figure in his government and
what he got up to and mount that case
for the defense when the front page of
the mail on Sunday which is hardly the
most hostile of newspapers in this
country says that the Prime Minister
himself said of Chris pincher he's
handsy that's a problem pincher by name
pincher by Nature who would be a cabinet
minister this morning Sophie who has to
defend the decision to reappoint Chris
pincher as a deputy chief whip just
earlier this year that's just one of the
reasons that made your interview with
trees coffee so striking well let's go
to some of it uh shall we um I thought
Sam as well it was quite interesting
because Therese coffee made it very
clear at one point that's what I was
told I thought that was quite an
interesting line from her but let's hear
a bit from Therese coffee at shall we I
started by asking her just how much the
Prime Minister knew about Chris
pincher's conduct before the allegations
on Wednesday night surfaced and
specifically of course when he made him
the deputy chief whip back in February
what's the Prime Minister aware of
allegations around Chris pinch's
behavior when he was made deputy chief
whip in February well I've just said to
you I'm not involved in any of those
direct conversations well why don't why
don't you ask that I just I don't you
know I I get you know perhaps it's
easier just to be able to come on these
programs and say look I don't know so
who knows but but surely you must ask to
try and find out you know that's the
first thing that most people would do
when did the Prime Minister know so that
when I am asked this question I can give
the answer
well as I've just outlined to you what
um has been suggested in terms of uh
things were referred uh but nevertheless
when somebody phoned the Prime Minister
uh particularly on Friday I think it was
um he agreed with the chief whip that
these uh whip should the witch should be
suspended when the appointment for
becoming deputy chief whip again
um moving from a different ministerial
post uh it was uh vet went through
vetting process like normal but as I say
I'm not directly involved in those
discussions um I'm not going to try and
do so and I'm not part of that more
General uh kind of rumor speculation
Mill within Westminster but nevertheless
sorry I'm just going to come in again
apologies
um
just gonna give you the same answer
Sophie but I don't I don't understand
the answer I forgive me you say it was
well laid out that he went through a
vetting process like normal but the
question is where was the Prime Minister
aware of allegations about his behavior
I'm not aware that he was made aware of
like specific claims about uh um any
particular incidents or anything like
that no I'm not I don't believe he was
aware that's what I've been told today
um but uh that's uh you were asking more
about more General rumors and I've no
idea what conversations have been had
I'm just not I am aware that he the
Prime Minister was not aware of specific
claims that have been made
oh there you go it did feel
um well it was one of those interviews
wasn't it I also asked the work and
pension secretary whether she personally
felt it was the right decision to
appoint Chris pincher to the role of
deputy chief whip given that there were
unspecific shall we say allegations that
were known about him
do you think that it was right for Chris
pincher to be appointed to that
important job in February
well what I think is right is that
people should have the confidence come
forward whether they want to do that
through the icgs which has been set out
obviously it's not the question that I
asked well I'm explaining that I think
it's important that people should have
the confidence to follow the procedures
that have been put in place deliberately
because of uh situations like this I'm
very wish people would go to the police
more with allegations uh if they feel uh
that a crime has been committed
uh let's bring in some coats so shall we
um like you say it is almost an
impossible position isn't it for people
like Cherise coffee what do you do just
go on what number 10 has told you but it
feels to me like this is quite
non-sustainable position at full number
10 this line uh that the Prime Minister
was not aware of specific allegations I
genuinely as I try to reflect on that
interview I'm really not sure what that
means but what constitutes a specific
allegation
well I think you're absolutely right
Sophie I I thought I learned so much
from that interview not quite from what
Terese coffee said but how she answered
your questions now listen what I mean by
that is it took four goes for you to get
something of an answer to the question
did the Prime Minister know about
allegations in advance now it was
entirely up to Terese coffee perhaps if
she strongly believed the line that
Boris Johnson had no idea to come out
hard fighting on behalf of the of the
Prime Minister fighting uh uh with the
Downing Street line up front that he
didn't know about any specific
allegations she could have barreled in
and made that point very firmly and I
think that Therese coffees reluctance to
do that use that line of defense that
she admitted she'd been given from
number 10 until the fourth time of
trying indicated there was something
going on in Therese coffee's brain that
suggested she just didn't want to make
that line of defense front and center
she wanted to say she wasn't involved in
the conversation she was let's let's be
honest about it she was D deeply
uncomfortable about the line she was
being asked by number 10 to use now that
must tell you both about the discomfort
that cabinet ministers are feeling but
also the fact that I still despite that
discomfort willing to come on shows like
yours and defend the government that is
a horrendous position as you say Sophie
it feels unsustainable but unsustainable
to what end I mean there is clearly
pressure growing once this investigation
is out of the way perhaps for Chris
pincher to be not only permanently
stripped the whip but maybe lose his
seat that would be a difficult uh
by-election uh an important by-election
for all sides in the Staffordshire seat
of Tamworth but what does Therese coffee
go away from this morning's interview
thinking what do other cabinet ministers
who don't believe the lines that they're
being asked by number 10 to defend go
away from mornings like this this
morning thinking or do they just think
well I'm doing good in cabinet I think
on balance this this government is a
good thing so I'm going to stick with it
and say whatever whatever's necessary
very difficult indeed let's bring in at
the labor action now shall we because we
did of course talk to Shadow business
secretary Jonathan Reynolds who had some
strong language about the incidence
lesson let's listen to him
yes we have problems I'm often a person
who has to respond and deal with those
but I can tell you that we don't have
what I observe in the conservative party
which is the repeated decision to make
the wrong decision if that's in whatever
short-term interest they perceive they
have I don't think they've taken these
things seriously I think they've made
decisions which they shouldn't have made
I can't believe some of the things that
are in the papers today about what the
Prime Minister may have personally been
aware of before he made decisions like
this and but all the politics suffers
that there was no doubt about that it it
affects the reputation of us all that's
what I find so frustrating and I think
it's right that people demand better
if you look at this particular instance
actually a few of them are in Parliament
itself so for me it comes down to
something bigger than the hospitality
Arrangements it's about power it's about
accountability it's about the the
standards that are set by the leader and
by the leader of each political party
and I cannot see Boris Johnson as being
the kind of person to somehow improve
the culture of the conservative party he
himself you know we don't even need to
go through the things that he has been
involved just to go back to the quest
just to go back to the question you
don't think there's a need to shut
parliament's bars then well I think
there is only one major bar for members
of parliament there's a one for staff as
well I'm not sure the other ones are
probably the restaurants but no I don't
think that is the issue I think the
problem is not you could shoot every bar
in Westminster but if you've got a
conservative party that does not take
these issues seriously that gives people
a get out of jail but genuinely you know
I do think most people listening to this
just won't understand like lots of
people work long hours lots of people
work late very very few people work in
workplaces where there is a drinking
culture that is effectively encouraged
because you have bars in Parliament
well I I wouldn't say it's encouraged
most people are doing an incredibly
professional job and where there are for
instance there's a bar for staff members
I think that is to be honest absolutely
fine what I'm trying to say to you is
this is not the core of the issue
that was uh Jonathan Reynolds there well
let's talk now to uh Sam coach shall we
it's funny it's listening back to that I
kind of sort of sense actually maybe my
frustration coming out slightly
um because we have lots of really strong
words from politicians about you know
the culture about power about protecting
uh vulnerable people and also just
everyone I guess in Parliament as well
and yet I've done so many of these
interviews over the years and nobody
feels it's actually willing to really
commit to any meaningful change in
Parliament it seems whether it's the
bars whether it's uh you know HR
practices between MPS and staff
there's not much in the words of
solutions is there
there isn't I mean I feel like I was
saying here just four to six weeks ago
and we were having a discussion about
whether or not the bars should shut and
whether or not the the way that MP staff
is employed uh should change in order to
tilt the balance a bit more in favor uh
of the staff and take a bit of the power
away from um MPS who uh uh wield so much
power
um uh for good but also occasionally for
ill and the answer from pretty much all
sides now I think you've got uh uh
because you put there from Johnny
Reynolds for Labor uh was no we don't
want to shut the bars no we don't want
to change the the employment contracts
we've got to be able to work uh with who
with who we want to
the argument is does culture change
because of structural changes like
closing the bar or is it a question of
leadership what the people at the top
want to make clear is and isn't
acceptable and that's clearly the
argument that labor want to run uh today
it's a lot of the argument I think that
frankly Tory MPS are making you saw
Karen Bradley uh come out with Caroline
dunnage on Friday uh uh making clear
that they think there should be a
tougher code of conduct for
conservatives but not being absolutely
um but this this idea not yet being
picked up by the conservatives but no
that there doesn't seem to be an
appetite for wholesale change in
Parliament but does doing those two
things in particular closing the bars
and changing the contracts really amount
to something that will cause big change
when there are so many bars within a
very short walking distance of
parliament uh or is it really all about
uh expectations set at the top uh yeah
it's interesting isn't it I guess the
counter argument to that is a of course
um just shutting the bars or changing HR
wouldn't eradicate bad behavior or even
more serious things than that but what
can you actually do about power and bad
behavior other than trying to make these
small but perhaps meaningful changes
that's right it's very hard uh to know
quite how to unpick in many ways life as
an MP in the houses of Parliament is a
bit more akin to some kind of a way day
conference MPS are away from their
families they work incredibly unusual
hours and I and I suspect it's that
working culture imposed by the fact that
people are coming from all over the
country to represent their MPS and vote
on laws often on anti-social times the
night that is behind the culture that we
talk about so often there have been
modifications to the operating hours of
parliament they're a bit more Humane
some days of the week but ultimately uh
there's a lot of like evening work
particularly some of those crunch votes
that we always report on happening at
five six seven eight at night no chance
for a lot of people to get home anything
like sensible hours and I do wonder
whether it's the hours rather than some
of the facilities in Parliament that
leads uh to uh the less acceptable
behavior okay Sam are always interesting
to talk thank you very much for giving
us your take this morning Suncoast
Deputy political Ed there
well that is it oh there you are that's
it from Sophia Ridge on Sunday the take
this morning thank you very much for uh
watching the podcast uh we'll be
following uh later today so do check
that one out uh otherwise see you
Wednesday evening 9pm the safety Ridge
the take
[Music]
[Music]
organisms
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Music]